and Jim Nantz is CBSsports lead
play-by-play announcer and is covering
the Masters for the 34th year and he
joins us from Augusta National Golf Club
Jim good morning hello friend it never
gets old watching that it never gets old
now I know maybe a lot of people can't
relate to this but what you just saw
that's my favorite sports moment of the
year you can talk about the Super Bowl
or that great championship game there
were fabulous games but as far as a
sports moment that's my favorite one
right there it's so rich in so many ways
the time-honored tradition just once a
year measurement of the passage of time
there's Jack and Gary hours as fans and
those who looked up to them as kids
growing up and it's just there's nothing
like it in any sport other than the
those first tee shots that augusto on a
Thursday morning yeah
arguably the greatest tournament in the
world let's talk about some of the
players this year Tiger Woods saying
this week I feel like I can win he
hasn't won a major championship since I
think the 2008 US Open how's he been
playing well he's been playing ok not as
great as he was playing at the end of
last year when he won an event in
September but he's been close I mean
he's been in the 15th to twenty-fifth
range and a lot of tournaments I think
he's going to play well this week the
one concern I would have is that he's
missed a lot of shorter putts than he
normally would but that can change a
little tip here they're from someone and
he certainly knows how to play a Gustin
national although it has been 14 years
since he last one here he tees off today
just a little after 11 o'clock local
time and I think that's a great point
for him to start and he's got a new
driver in his bag and I am expecting the
tiger will once again be in contention
here Rory McIlroy coming off a win at
last month's player championship trying
for his first Grand Slam how about that
well actually you only win the Grand
Slam one time you can repeat it if you
want all those majors another time so
you could have like two swings through
the Grand Slam I guess but the key thing
is he'd only be the sixth player in
history to complete
the grand slam he's won the other three
he's been close here he was in the final
pairing last year he's playing today
just directly behind the tiger grouping
and that me this is history-making stuff
if Rory can join the likes of Gene
Sarazen and Tiger and Jack Nicklaus and
and Ben Hogan and complete the grand
slam and he seems to be in in really
good form and I'm expecting that come
Sunday it's gonna be whether or not all
of that suffocating pressure is going to
be something he can withstand and I like
this kid a lot I think he can I think he
can definitely pull it off this week Jim
picking up on that suffocating pressure
I was struck that the last four winners
at the Masters have all been first-time
major winners I mean this is the biggest
stage yeah just watching them tee off
there I got nervous what does that say
to you that the last four are first-time
major winners
well first off good for you John because
I'm feeling those same nerves I'm
thinking maybe it's just me but I'm
feeling the nervousness for them to get
the ball airborne and you know Jack and
Gary pulled it off although Jack you
could see wasn't thrilled with his tee
shot I'm a little surprised by that too
that's some insightful stuff that we've
had four consecutive years of a of a
first-time winner it's just a testament
though to the depth of the sport right
now like we haven't talked about Brooks
koepka
you know everybody wants to talk about
Tiger he hasn't won this tournament 14
years
Brooks kept cos won two of the last
three major championships played three
of the last six he's played in and no
one talks about him but again Tiger is
the biggest star we have in the game and
you know with Jack the greatest champion
we've ever had but there are so many
guys that we're not even going to talk
about they come in here whether it's
Justin Thomas or Justin Rose or Dustin
Johnson it's just there are so many guys
that are capable winning and I think
that's the answer your question the the
quality of the depth and the game right
now is best ever in my mind
well 34 years and I have to tell you Jim
as you know I'm not a golfer don't
really know a lot about this game except
I love love Bubba Watson but what is it
about it for you because your enthusiasm
really is infectious about it
every time I talk about this game I mean
thank you
Thank You Gail and I love visiting with
you guys I hope you know that but for me
this is the childhood dream when I was a
little boy this was the this was the
thing that really inspired me to want to
one day be a voice behind the Masters
Tournament I mean people that know me
from my from my days in my in my teens
they would tell you that I used to walk
around saying one day I want to be at
the Masters it's the greatest event of
all it's deep in my heart and I feel
very fortunate Virginia basketball coach
Tony Bennett there with you we gotta go
he's not no he wants to come here yes
yeah thank you all thank you so much we
love you Jim Nantz we love Augusta we
love watching this really looking for it
thank you so much you can also stream
CBS Sports coverage of the entire
Masters Tournament online at CBS Sports
comm and CBS will broadcast the action
live starting Saturday at 3:00 p.m.
Eastern